JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: I'm
sitting with two very talented
people, as those bios suggest.
So, I know the "Eleven
Madison Park"
cookbook came out in 2011.
Two years later we have "I Love
New York." Are you guys
really authors disguised
as restaurateurs?
How did this book come
about so quickly?
WILL GUIDARA: No.
When we did the "Eleven Madison
Park" book, the funny
story about that was in the very
beginning we were pretty
naive, and we didn't really
know what went into a
book of that size.
And we started, it was the two
of us and our assistant, and
the idea was that we would write
the book and she would
test the recipes.
And we had the whole thing
figured out and we thought it
was going to be nice and easy.
And fast forward about three
weeks from there, and the
entire restaurant was kind of
collapsing on itself, because
Amy was never in the office--
she was always trying to
cook-- and we realized we needed
to figure out a more
effective approach.
And so, by the time we had
really kind of engaged in the
process of "Eleven Madison
Park," there were about 10
people on a team working
on that book.
And when we finished it, like
when you finish anything,
there is that element of kind
of celebration that we'd
finished it, and then
sadness that we no
longer had a project.
And so, we kind of just kept
going, and we just took the
team, and we had been
fantasizing about this idea
for a while, and we just
got right back into it.
So, it happened a lot more
quickly, I think, than either
one of us would have imagined.
But as a fun book to work on.
DANIEL HUMM: Also what was cool
is that it was a year of
kind of like the quiet
before the storm.
It was way before
NoMad opened.
But as you might know, a book
takes a good year to produce,
and then it takes another
year to be published.
So, really we produced the book
two years ago, and now
everyone is like wow,
how were you able to
also produce a book?
But the reality is that it
really was produced before we
opened, before we started
conceptualizing and opening NoMad.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: You're
time travelers.
It's what you do, OK.
And 50 of the farms, or over
50 of the farms featured in
this book are actually located
150 miles outside of New York
City or less.
So do you think readers are
going to be surprised with how
agricultural the state is?
WILL GUIDARA: I mean I was
surprised as a chef, cooking
here at that time for
already five years.
It's just unbelievable.
We have the Atlantic Ocean,
which is some of the best
water for seafood
in the world.
It's really cold water.
It produces really sweet
[INAUDIBLE] fish and
incredible fish.
And then we have the Hudson
Valley, which is one of the
best growing regions for
root vegetables,
but also stone fruits--
apples and pears.
And you know it has so
many different types
of climate, of soil.
There is a soil that, it's
around the Hudson Valley.
It's pitch black, pitch black
like this floor, and it's
called the muck soil.
And the carrot it produces,
it's unbelievable.
We have this one guy, his name
is Alex [INAUDIBLE].
He's been farming
for 40 years.
And he farms a couple of
things, but he's really
focused on carrots, and he grows
20 or 30 different types
of carrots.
And this soil, which is also
very sandy, the carrots that
it produces is unbelievable--
how sweet it is.
And then in the 25 different
carrots, it's from really
sweet carrots to carrots even
a little bit spicy, earthy.
It's just unbelievable.
I was blown away.
I mean that's kind of how
we felt like this
story had to be told.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: And the
carrots at NoMad are famed.
So is that the secret, going
to this farm and getting
those, or can anyone accomplish
that taste at home?
WILL GUIDARA: I mean
definitely.
We're chefs and there is only so
much you can do as a chef.
There's a whole other spectrum
that happens before the
ingredient arrives in the
kitchen, and that is all in
the farmer's hands.
And since this process, since
we got really close with the
farms, we're actually able to
affect the process even before
it comes to the kitchen.
When we have a dish and we talk
to the farmer, we say we
want a carrot that's--
just staying with the carrot, it
could be anything-- but we
want a carrot that's a little
spicy, we want a carrot that's
this, we want a carrot--
a certain size.
We can really control
a lot of--
Or we can say you know what, we
want to have 10 different
carrots that nobody
has heard before.
We want to grow some really
old hair long carrots.
And with these relationships,
really the sky's the limit.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: So can you
guys start a CSA for us?
[LAUGHTER]
WILL GUIDARA: I think one of
the things that a lot of
people have been asking, OK, you
can call a book I love New
York, and it works everywhere
because it's New York, right.
But a lot of people have been
saying, OK, how do you use
this book if you don't
live in New York?
And I do believe that there's an
element of this that's more
just about the spirit
of the book.
And I think to that point,
when you think
internationally, at the very
least, when people think about
New York, they think of
Manhattan, and people don't
even know how much just amazing
product comes from
around here.
But that's also the case in a
lot of places in America where
people are so focused on this
ingredient from there and this
ingredient from there that they
don't take the time to
look in their backyard, and
oftentimes, what's there is
going to yield you a much better
dish and then a much
better meal than anything that
you can get from importing it
just because of how long it's
been out of the ground or just
the care with which it's
being produced.
But it was also an exciting
story for us to tell because
we do get to travel a lot.
That's one of the benefits of
what we do is we kind of, as a
requirement, need to go and
experience some of the great
restaurants out there.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Boo-hoo.
Everyone's crying for you.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah, exactly.
So we've been to Rome and Tokyo
and Piedmont, Lyon, and
when you go to the great
restaurants in these places,
like the three Michelin star
restaurants, there's an
amazing sense of place.
You know that you're there when
you're in a perfect Hush
sushi bar in Tokyo, that meal
almost wouldn't even make
sense anywhere else
in the world.
Similarly, when you're in
Piedmont during truffle season
or this or that.
And yet, in New York, which we
believe is the greatest dining
city in the world, it's
not that way.
And it's kind of a blessing
and a curse.
It's a blessing because here we
can get everything in the
world simply by picking up the
phone or going to one of the
local kind of neighborhoods
that's a
microcosm of that place.
But when you go to the great
restaurants in New York
there's a sense of place
oftentimes in Piedmont or Lyon
or Tokyo or Paris.
And so it's been fun for us
to join the conversation.
It's not just us having-- and
I think some great chefs and
restaurateurs in New York are
focusing on this now, that New
York is the greatest dining city
in the world, and it's
about time we find what does
New York cuisine mean.
What does dining in New York
actually consist of, if it's
unique within the world, and
based on what's growing around
here, and also based on so much
of the history and the
traditions that have
taken root here.
It was a really fun thing for
us to learn about, to talk
about, and then to really begin
to integrate into the
restaurants.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: And I know
in the introduction to
the book you touch upon that.
So it was partially created to
begin the conversation, what
is New York cuisine.
So now that you've written
it, do you have
an appropriate answer?
WILL GUIDARA: What is
New York cuisine?
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Yeah.
WILL GUIDARA: I mean you've
got to buy the book.
That's the whole thing.
[LAUGHTER]
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
Fair enough.
And I know that Eleven Madison
Park underwent a menu change
at the end of last year.
So, do you both feel that the
process of writing the book
changed your approach to both
of your restaurants?
DANIEL HUMM: Writing this book
has definitely made us
re-think everything we were
doing, and it has definitely
influenced the recent changes
at Eleven Madison Park.
But to the question before, what
is New York cuisine, I
think that is a really
open-ended question, and the
book will have some answers, but
it's not going to answer
everything.
And I think we're just
onto something.
I think we're just at the
beginning of something.
You know, growing up in
Switzerland, I grew up in a
very small town of
1,000 people.
And the surrounding towns were
fairly small as well.
And each of the towns had a
local specialty, like the town
I'm from has a special type of
chocolate that's stuffed with
marzipan and special--
like a liqueur from the
apples that we grow.
And the town next to it
has a famous sausage.
Other towns have famous baked
goods, famous vegetables, a
special type of cherry
that they grow.
Every small town has that.
And so, whenever I travel,
I look for those.
And when I go to a new place I
say OK, what makes this place
special in terms of food,
in terms of ingredients.
And so, it was no different
coming to New York.
And it's kind of hard to see
because in New York we have
everything, and if we don't
have it, we fly it in, and
whatever you want.
We fly in fish from Japan
and olive oil
from Italy and whatever.
But when I came here I really
wanted to dig a little deeper
and to see what has been created
here, and what grows
here the best.
And I think it is the two things
together that makes a
cuisine to its place.
I think it's the agriculture
and the history as well.
So like the egg creams, the
Bloody Marys, the black and
white cookies, the lobster
thermidor, or baked Alaska,
steak tartar, potato chips.
I mean there's so many
things that--
the oysters.
There were like 50 years of
New York where people ate
oysters, like a pound of oysters
per day per person.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: I wish.
DANIEL HUMM: I mean oyster
was like the thing.
This was called the
oyster island.
So that's what we're really
trying to define and trying to
just do more research
and dig deeper.
And what's exciting is I think
we just scratched the surface.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: So, in
your travels throughout New
York, was there anything that
really surprised you?
WILL GUIDARA: I think that we
had a list of farms that we
were going to go check out
that were either farms we
learned about or farms that
we're using, farms that we had
at least up until that
point, held in
very, very high esteem.
The surprises came in
different ways.
One, farms that we hadn't really
heard that much about
that were just unbelievable in
the care and the attention and
what was actually being
produced there.
And then there were the farms
that we thought were
unbelievable, and then when we
got there we're like oh, my
goodness, I can't believe we've
been buying from these
people for this long.
There's 55 in the book, but I
think we probably went to
about 65 or 75 before we were
able to kind of cull down the
list of this.
We spent a lot of time in a car
together, and spent a lot
of nights in these random hotels
in upstate New York as
we were kind of exploring.
This book is arguably more
accessible and simpler than
the "Eleven Madison Park" book,
but it took a lot more
work to put this one together
because it was not just a book
of recipes.
It required getting to know each
one of the farmers and
kind of well enough we're able
to tell their story.
Because it's cool the amount of
trust that they give you.
These people, who we didn't know
very well, allowed us to
tell their story to the world.
And some of the stories just
beyond the food, beyond the
stories of the traditions, but
the stories of these people.
And it's amazing.
They kind of shoot the entire
gamut in terms of where
they're from and how
they ended up doing
what they're doing.
It was really fun.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: And
seems like some real
characters as well.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah.
Well, you have everything from
the jaded lawyers or people
that work on internet companies,
like they can't do
it anymore and they move
out to Long Island.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
What do you mean?
[LAUGHTER]
WILL GUIDARA: That
was intentional.
And then there were the people
that are fourth generation and
had always been doing one thing
and then the food craze
is taking over and they wanted
to do something better.
But yeah, the pictures of some
of these, it's amazing.
DANIEL HUMM: But also, I truly
believe that when there is a
connection to the product, when
you know exactly where
it's from, it just
tastes better.
Like I remember as a child, when
we would go out and went
to forage mushrooms, or
we went to pick fresh
strawberries and then we
made a strawberry pie.
All these things, it just
tastes so much better.
So, I think the more people of
our team we can get to the
farm and get to know the
farmer, the more we can
translate that to the guests.
The more passion there is, the
more care there is, when the
cooks know where it's from and
how much work it takes to get
to this product.
You know, certain things at the
restaurant, we're using
all these little small
chanterelle mushrooms, for
example, or the tristar
strawberries, also very tiny.
And when you see what it takes
to get to that, the way you
care for it is a
lot different.
And then in the dining room, if
they know the same thing,
then the way they present it
to the guests, they're much
more excited about it because
they know how special it is.
And then in the end, I think
the guests get the benefit
from that, from that passion
and excitement about the
people who grow it and
about what they grow.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Have the
farmers ever come to the
restaurant?
WILL GUIDARA: We threw a big
party at this loft down in
Tribeca when we released the
book, and we invited all 55 of
them, and I think about
33 of them came.
And it was awesome.
So our entire staff getting
to interact with them, and
definitely it was a very
cosmopolitan scene, and there
was definitely a juxtaposition
going on.
But we also have classes--
we're only open for dinner four
nights of the week at
Eleven Madison, so we have the
entire afternoon to have
classes and presentations
and whatnot.
And so, we open for dinner
service at 5:30, but all of
our team is there, at the
latest, by like 1:00 in the
afternoon, and we'll either do
wine tastings or cocktail
classes, or this or that
because that's
what we're all into.
The farmers will come down and
talk about the ingredient.
I think with the dining room
staff, you have a better time
at dinner when the person
serving you is excited about
what they're serving you.
And when they've gotten to meet
the person, it just makes
that much more fun, and you
learn a lot of stuff that you
didn't even know you didn't
know, and that's what's cool.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: I know you
guys are big music fans.
So you said Eleven Madison
Park is Miles Davis.
NoMad was the Rolling Stones.
You've mentioned road trip.
So what inspired this
book, musically?
WILL GUIDARA: You know,
we didn't have--
the music is for the
restaurants, not the book.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
No road trip jam?
WILL GUIDARA: No, but we did
a video, and a lot of our
friends are musicians, so any
time we do a video we get one
of them to write some music and
the directions for kind of
an inspiration for the song that
accompanied the video for
this book was Mumford and Sons,
for what that's worth.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: And you
also mentioned the book party.
So, you guys are getting
somewhat
notorious for your parties.
You've got the James Beard
award parties.
I know you throw a Derby
party every year--
DANIEL HUMM: It's all him.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: --at
Eleven Madison Park.
So what's the success behind
throwing a successful party?
What's the secret,
I should say.
WILL GUIDARA: The secret to
throwing a successful party.
DANIEL HUMM: A lot of booze.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah,
a lot of booze.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL GUIDARA: Live music.
I think a party without live
music, there's a problem, or a
really, really good DJ.
We have this one woman DJ,
Bonnie, who does all of our
after hours parties.
No, I mean in the same way that
a server is excited about
the food makes you
excited of food.
We love entertaining people.
And we love doing it through
fine dining, we love doing it
through cocktails at NoMad, but
we get the same pleasure
out of bringing a ton of people
together and having
them have a good time.
I mean for me--
and I'm the dining room guy,
he's the kitchen guy, and
that's why I do what I do
because I just love showing
people a good time.
And when we're in the dining
room, we're there
to only serve you.
When we throw a party, we're
there to party with you.
And so, you get a different side
of our personalities a
little bit.
DANIEL HUMM: Once there's no
police, the other times the
police breaks it up.
[LAUGHTER]
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Is there a
particular incident in which
the police came?
WILL GUIDARA: Oh, we had a
party this year after the
Beard Awards in this
loft space that
friends of ours have.
And it was a really, really
good party, and--
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: And all
really good parties end with
the cops coming.
WILL GUIDARA: With the cops.
But that DJ I was talking about,
DJ Bonnie who is kind
of a little bit of a spiritual
leader for me--
a, we lost the Beard award that
night, and we hadn't lost
a Beard award in a long time.
And so, at the beginning
of the party she said--
and she speaks in this like
thick, maple syrupy way-- and
she's like baby doll,
don't worry.
She was like if you win
every year people are
going to hate you.
And so she made me feel good.
And then on the way out, as she
was like wading her way
through the cops as she was
leaving the party, she gave me
a high five without even looking
me in the eyes, and
she goes, baby, it's bad ass
when your party gets broken up
by the cops.
So, DJ Bonnie made me
feel very good a
few times that night.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: So you've
got DJ Bonnie, you've
got Miles Davis, you've got
the Rolling Stones.
So what do you think
the correlation is
between music and food?
WILL GUIDARA: It's not
music and food only.
Its music and the experience.
So, the whole Miles Davis
thing is because in the
beginning at Eleven Madison
Park, we get a review in the
"New York Observer," and at
the end she said that she
wished we had a bit more
Miles Davis in us.
And we kind of responded to that
without totally knowing
what it meant.
And then a couple weeks later
it was still resonating with
both of us.
So we read a bunch about Miles
and came up with a list of
words that were most commonly
used to describe him.
And in that list were words like
endless reinvention, and
vibrant, and fresh, and light,
and spontaneous.
And that kind of became the
mission statement for Eleven
Madison Park.
And now in the kitchen we have
photos of Miles that the guys
at Sony Records have given us,
and it really is kind of a
permeating theme, where I think
in any organization
there's an incredible
power with language
to help guide you.
So when we were getting ready
to open NoMad, we needed an
artist as well.
And the thing with
the Stones are--
the Stones, we wanted NoMad to
be fun, loud, loose, a bit
crazy, and I think that's
what the Stones are.
But if you read about the
Rolling Stones, when they were
coming up, they were so
deliberate and studied and
intentional with everything
they did.
If a new blues album came out
from the South in America,
they buy it, learn every song
note for note, break it down
and dissect it.
In doing so, I think the Stones
revolutionized music
with like kind of R&B, and
blues, and kind of weaving
those all together.
And so, what we want NoMad to
be is crazy and chaotic and
fun, but intentional.
And it's just something that the
two of us have both always
related to pretty well.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: You're
both innovators.
So when it comes to cookbooks,
where do you see the
technological advances going to
kind of make things easier
for consumers?
Now you guys have an email
address in the introduction to
your book that people
can reach out.
Do people use that?
DANIEL HUMM: No.
The email address
gets used a lot.
And it was really important
for us that some of the
recipes are a little
less accessible.
We didn't really want to
sacrifice, especially with the
"Eleven Madison Park" book, we
wanted to really show what we
do at the restaurant.
And I think in the "I Love New
York" cookbook, it's a good
mix, but some recipes are a
little bit more challenging.
So we really wanted to make sure
they're accessible in a
way that there's always somebody
there to talk to.
And we do get still, for the
"Eleven Madison Park" book, we
get about five emails a week
with questions, and now with
this one we get a lot
more, obviously.
But we're trying to get back to
people really quickly, in
the first day or so.
But you know, it's interesting,
I ask myself a
lot, because at some point I was
wondering if we should be
kind of a leader with
the e-books.
And I collect a lot of books,
and I have them at home, and
it's really beautiful to
have real books still.
So I'm not sure--
and it hasn't really taken off
as fast as I thought it would.
So I'm not sure exactly
where it's going.
I still feel a real
book is beautiful.
And I think it's very cool what
some websites do with the
recipes there's little videos,
and it definitely can give you
more in that sense.
But as far as the spirit of a
restaurant or of a state, I
feel like the book has more
soul, and maybe it's just me
the way I'm used to-- you know
I've been collecting cookbooks
since I'm 12 years old, so
for me there's something
special about it.
So, I'm not sure how it's
going to look like.
WILL GUIDARA: I feel like
cookbooks are just one of the
last things that people
actually want
in the printed form.
I buy--
I travel with my iPad, and if
I'm buying a book I buy it
from an iPad, but a cookbook,
you use them.
I think in the introduction to
the first one we said we want
this book either beautifully
presented on your coffee table
or lovingly stained
in the kitchen.
But please, treat it as such.
I'm just--
I'm happy that there's still a
book genre that is selling
well in printed form.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Last time
you guys were here was
February, 2012, right
before NoMad opened.
How have things changed since
then, besides the obvious
opening of NoMad.
WILL GUIDARA: He had
a new daughter--
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
Congratulations.
WILL GUIDARA: --Coco, who's my
goddaughter, and that's the
closest I've come to having my
own children, so that's been
exciting for me, maybe a little
bit exciting for him.
DANIEL HUMM: He has a
few more gray hairs.
WILL GUIDARA: I have, in
general, less hair, and then
within that hair,
more gray hair.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL GUIDARA: No, we're busier,
but our team is
bigger, and in a way
we have more time.
In a really bizarre way we're
doing a lot more than we ever
did before.
But it's really great.
I think this is, obviously, an
optimistic time in New York.
Any time you're being
interviewed at the beginning
of spring, you're always like
oh, man, life is awesome.
I love everything
and everyone.
And it's true.
But we've been very lucky in how
our team has evolved and
grown, and how, in spite of the
fact that, the number of
things on our to-do list have
grown exponentially, we've
maintained a similar pace and
balance and ability to juggle
things and handle them I think
pretty well, in spite of some
issues and road bumps
along the way.
DANIEL HUMM: You know, in the
grand scheme of things, I
think sometimes you get caught
up in your world and you feel
like you're ruling the world,
but in the end of the day
we're running two little
restaurants and they're so
close from each other.
So, when you put things in
perspective, and we have an
amazing team.
So it's not that
big of a deal.
I mean other people save lives
and we're just serving meals
to people, and luckily
there's enough
people who want to come.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
So, a very grounded
world view to have.
I don't think anyone else would
say Eleven Madison Park
is small, but fair enough.
So, for any of you who haven't
eaten at Eleven Madison Park,
at the end of the meal they
present you with granola, and
I'm not sure if the woman who
was here February, 2012 is
currently in our audience, but
she asked what's happening
with the granola.
We all want it.
We want to have it at home.
What are the plans
for the business.
Is it still an option?
WILL GUIDARA: I would imagine
our answer at the time was
hey, we're actually thinking
about maybe--
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Yes.
You're like it's in the
works, it's happening.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah, it's
not happening anymore.
No, I think that we're
both super excitable.
We get really excited about
things, and one of things that
we're working very, very hard
to do is not get too
distracted by different
things.
Maybe one day it'll happen.
My dad just retired and it's
great when your dad retires.
It's scary, also, however,
when-- and my dad was in the
restaurant business.
And so he's like well,
this is great.
I have all this time.
I can really help you out with
your business, and then that's
a scary thing.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
I was going to say.
Why can't he do it then?
WILL GUIDARA: Well then, so then
he called the other day.
He's like what if I do
the granola thing?
I was like Dad, no,
no, no, no, no.
So maybe my dad will
start selling our
granola at some point.
[LAUGHTER]
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
Let us know.
And you've been working together
at this point now for
seven years, so how has the
collaboration changed?
Obviously you guys
are very close.
DANIEL HUMM: You know, I
think it's incredible.
I feel so lucky, or we feel so
lucky that we have really
found each other.
I think it's so much more
fun to have a partner.
It's just something you
have to work on.
It doesn't come just easily
all the time because your
personal life changes,
and work changes.
You're surrounded by
different people.
You have more restaurants, the
press, and all the things that
are around.
And so you constantly need to
work on it, but I think it's
stronger than it
has ever been.
I think there was a time where
we kind of made the decision
to really be together and build
something together.
And I think from that moment
on things really started to
come together for us.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah, I think--
we're very close, obviously.
And not every day is a good day,
and on the bad the bad
days are never that bad when you
feel absolute support from
your business partner.
I think that's really,
really comforting.
I think we've had to learn
how to disagree.
I think there were years where
we just agreed on everything
and it made working together
super, super easy.
We don't always agree on
everything, and that's--
I think it's a skill.
And we always talk about it
kind of half jokingly, but
sincerely it's like marriage.
And when you talk to the
people that have been
successfully married for 50
years or something, they
always talk about just being
very intentional in your
pursuit of a healthy
relationship.
We're friends with this family
that owns a restaurant in
Seattle called Canlis, and
it's a third generation
restaurant, so it was opened
by the grandfather and then
run by the parents for a long
time, and now the kids who are
very close friends of ours are
running the restaurant.
And their Dad is just one of
these sage, wise men who, when
you're with him, everything he's
saying you know you're
receiving some brilliant
advice.
Every time we're with him, he
never even tries to advise us
on what we're actually doing
in the restaurant.
It's only just him kind of
speaking into our relationship
and our lives.
The thing that I think separates
Eleven Madison Park
and the NoMad is that they're
not chef-driven restaurants or
restaurateur-driven
restaurants.
They're restaurants that are
founded upon the collaboration
between the kitchen and the
dining room, and it starts
with us, but it cascades through
the entire staff.
Our staffs are really,
really close.
There's this old kitchen thing
where when a cook, who has
been at a restaurant for a long
time leaves, on their
last day they get dumped in
a big, big ice bucket.
That's like a thing
that's kind of--
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
That's right.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah,
it's terrible.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Anyone
want to work at a restaurant?
WILL GUIDARA: But that's like
every great restaurant out
there has some vestige
of that.
And it was a very proud
day for me.
It was about a year and a half
ago when I saw the cooks
dumping one of the dining room
staff into the ice bucket, and
we knew we'd kind of finally
arrived in that collaboration.
But I think it's super,
super important.
DANIEL HUMM: How do you feel
when you get dumped in?
WILL GUIDARA: That's why we
bought the restaurant, so I
never le I'm good.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: And Danny
Meyer actually spoke
about traditions like that when
he was here last month
talking about "The Family
Table," his book.
And so we actually asked him to
prepare of couple questions
to ask you.
So, the first one from Danny
Meyer is you two were born
innovating, and each innovation
has worked out
incredibly well.
How do you respond when people
question your drive to disrupt
the status quo?
And while you're thinking about
that background, in case
anyone doesn't know, Danny Meyer
was mentor to both of
you prior to you moving
on your own.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah.
So we're both very sensitive,
and I think that that is a
requirement in doing
what we do.
If you're not sensitive, you're
not open to the needs
of the people you're
trying to serve.
And if you're not sensitive
enough, you're not going to be
good enough at reading the
guests and figuring out what
to give them.
But the dangerous part is yeah,
when people say mean
stuff it hurts a little bit.
But I think chef has actually
been really good for me in
this way, which is that the
further down the line you go,
if you're really trying to do
something new and special and
innovative, the less likely
it is that you're
going to please everybody.
And so, we work very, very hard
to find balance between
listening to everything that's
said without being so reactive
that you change every time
someone says something.
Because then you don't actually
have a point of view,
you're just trying to please
everyone, and in doing so,
watering down the message that
you're trying to convey.
But, I mean those are the most
difficult times in our
relationship, too, because
sometimes I'll be like no,
they said they didn't like
it, we need to change it.
And he'll say no, no, no.
We need to stay the course,
we believe in this.
We've spent time preparing for
this, and one person can't
throw us off what we're trying
to do, and other times it
might be the other way around.
But I think the answer is we
listen to everything, and then
at the end of the day you need
to just decide what you
believe is right, and I think
that that's how we've been
trying to handle those things.
It's a well-articulated
question though.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
I'd expect nothing
less from him, right.
WILL GUIDARA: Good job, Danny.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: So the
second question that he had
for you was you two have derived
enormous inspiration
from Miles Davis.
Some day a restaurant is
going to put up words
inspired by you two.
What would those words be?
WILL GUIDARA: There's no way
to answer this question
without being attacked somehow.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL GUIDARA: No, you know
what is really cool?
There's a restaurant in London
that put a sign up on their
wall in the kitchen that says,
"Would Eleven Madison Park do
it like that?" And we saw that
randomly on Twitter, and it
was the coolest thing for
our entire staff.
And now that restaurant has
actually been sending their
staff, two people every
single month.
The guy gave them his credit
card and they come to New
York, and that feels
really good.
I mean
I think it's way too premature
in our careers to really think
about that, but for
our entire team--
there's 135 people that work at
Eleven Madison Park, and I
think one of our biggest goals
on a day-to-day basis is to
make sure that their
gas tanks are full.
And when things like that
happen it's gold.
It's amazing.
DANIEL HUMM: The one word I
want to be there is fun.
I think that's something that's
really important to us,
and I hope that people
will see that.
And I think the other words is
for other people to decide.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: We're
going to finish our chat with
a couple of fill in the blanks,
and for those of you
in the audience that
have questions,
there are two mic stands.
And I believe books being sold
in the back if you want to
purchase those as well.
So if you want to start
queuing up.
So, fill in the blank.
Whatever comes to mind.
WILL GUIDARA: We struggled with
the fill in the blank
portion of this interview
last time.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
That's OK.
WILL GUIDARA: So,
now I'm like--
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Second
go, a little more relaxed.
WILL GUIDARA: --if my body
language is showing.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: The most
challenging part of my job is?
WILL GUIDARA: See,
here we go again.
It's really hard.
I'd say that to your point
before, the most challenging
part of my job is when
we let someone down.
Like we have really, really
high expectations for what
we're trying to do, and
when you disappoint
someone, it's the worst.
DANIEL HUMM: The most
challenging part of my job is
to channel the ideas, because we
can't do them all, and kind
of prioritize what we want to be
and what we want to do, to
the point of the granola
business.
That had to go away, even we
were super excited about it.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: It'll
happen one day.
DANIEL HUMM: There's
a lot of great--
WILL GUIDARA: One day.
DANIEL HUMM: --ideas we have,
and we have to stay focused.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
If I wasn't in this
industry, I would be?
WILL GUIDARA: I'd
be a musician.
I play the drums.
There was like a point in my
life where I had to decide
whether I wanted to try to
continue being a drummer or go
into the restaurant business,
or stay in the restaurant
business, and I realize that I
could own restaurants and play
the drums, but I probably
couldn't play the drums and
try to be restaurateur
at the same time.
But it's one of the cool--
that's one of the reasons we
have these parties.
We have all this live music,
because in doing what we do,
we get to really be connected
to music and have a lot of
great musicians around us.
DANIEL HUMM: I think I would
probably be in cycling.
As a junior, I was on the
Swiss national team for
mountain biking.
And when I was 18 years old
I kind of had to make a
decision, professional
cycling or cooking.
And with everything that went on
with the doping scandal, I
think I made the right choice.
[LAUGHS]
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Yeah.
WILL GUIDARA: He rode his bike
95 miles on Saturday.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
Oh, my goodness.
WILL GUIDARA: I can't--
I mean just saying that out
loud, especially on a Monday
morning is--
So, I respect this man's
physical endurance much more
than my own.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
Pretty impressive.
I hate it when I get asked?
WILL GUIDARA: Um, to
fill in the blanks.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL HUMM: I hate when
I get asked what's
your favorite dish?
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: In my
fridge I always have?
WILL GUIDARA: Sriracha.
I don't have very much
in my fridge.
I have normally a six pack of
Stella, and then some sriracha
for whatever I end
up ordering.
But we're not there
very often.
DANIEL HUMM: In my fridge, I
always have Swiss chocolate.
WILL GUIDARA: That's
so cliche.
DANIEL HUMM: I know.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL GUIDARA: That one--
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
Let him have it.
WILL GUIDARA: --with the apple
liqueur and the marzipan.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL HUMM: From my home.
WILL GUIDARA: From
your home town.
[LAUGHTER]
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Gotta
bring a piece of you home with
you always.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah, sure.
DANIEL HUMM: [LAUGHS]
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: The most
ridiculous thing that's
happened during one of the
parties we've thrown is?
WILL GUIDARA: I mean I don't--
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
Too many to count.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah, I can't--
I can't with--
DANIEL HUMM: No, the one time
he was like standing on the
bar and he was starting taking
his clothes off.
That was insane.
WILL GUIDARA: That is not
even a little bit true.
I just want to make that--
[LAUGHTER]
WILL GUIDARA: --very,
very clear.
We could move on to
the next one.
[LAUGHTER]
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: OK.
Sensitive topic.
Moving on.
My hangover cure is?
WILL GUIDARA: You know, I
recently heard apple juice is
the best care for hangovers.
I never tried it.
I'm a purest.
I drink coffee.
DANIEL HUMM: I mean there's a
lot of cures that he, over the
years, tried to teach me.
One has been drink
a Manhattan.
The other one has been either
a Big Mac at McDonald's.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL GUIDARA: What are you
painting me to be right now?
[LAUGHTER]
WILL GUIDARA: He goes running.
WILL GUIDARA: That's
what he does.
I'll answer that one for you.
DANIEL HUMM: For me, none
of them have worked out.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: OK.
OK.
So is it running then?
DANIEL HUMM: That is.
It's like a reset button.
WILL GUIDARA: It drives
me crazy.
Like we'll be in Piedmont and
we'll have this huge meal with
way too much wine and I wake
up just feeling terrible.
And then he just like--
[LAUGHTER]
WILL GUIDARA: He like comes,
and he's oh, hey, Will.
Just ran 30 miles,
and I'm so Swiss.
[LAUGHTER]
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Does he
eat a chocolate bar when he's
saying that?
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah, exactly.
With a spicy carrot
or something.
[LAUGHTER]
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: And then
the last one is my greatest
food indulgence is?
WILL GUIDARA: I mean I guess
there's different words to
describe the word indulgent,
or-- yeah.
DANIEL HUMM: I think being in
Piedmont and eating a lot of
white truffles and pasta,
that's pretty special.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah, there's
the luxuriousness.
I think white truffles is
definitely the thing that
would top that list.
But I'm 33 now, and in the
last two years I finally
realized that I'm not going
to just be thin forever.
And so now indulgence also comes
in just eating unhealthy
stuff, and I'll say what
I said last time.
Like a double-double from In and
Out Burger, that's one of
my greatest indulgence.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
Fair enough.
I believe we've got
a question.
DANIEL HUMM: Animal style.
WILL GUIDARA: Animal style.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Can't
forget that important detail.
AUDIENCE: Congratulations with
the San Pellegrino list.
WILL GUIDARA: Thank
you so much.
AUDIENCE: I have a two-part
question.
The first is the carrot tartar,
which I think is
really fun and what of
the more memorable
parts of your menu.
Did you try with other
vegetables or ingredients
while you were testing
that out?
And was there anything--
like did you ever thought about
putting just like a hunk
of rib-eye in and see
what happens?
DANIEL HUMM: You know honestly,
that's where the
idea started.
Steak tartar has such a history
in New York, and it's
been served for many years in
the greatest restaurants.
And so, we kind of wanted
to do our own version.
And so we were playing around
with meat, but then
different--
the stuff that goes in it to
make it different or the fact
that we were doing it
at the table we
thought it was different.
But then eating it, it wasn't
quite different enough.
So one day I came back from that
farm and I had a whole
create of all these different
carrots, and they were just
playing around with it, with
this old school meat grinder
that you've seen.
And somehow I just didn't like
it and I'd been thinking about
it, but then the carrots and
seeing the meat grinder, I'm
like let's try carrot.
And everyone was looking
saying, carrots?
And I wasn't sure either.
But then we did it and we
worked around with the
garnishes that went into--
and it's pretty unbelievable.
I think if you have your eyes
closed and somebody would feed
it to you, you would definitely
think steak tartar
right away.
You might not even know that
there is no meat, because
these carrots are so
earthy and rich.
And then you have these
garnishes with the acid and
this sour and the spicy,
and it just made sense.
So that's how it happened.
AUDIENCE: That's awesome.
And also, in this book, which
recipe did you guys
resonate most with?
And also, Will, which one have
you successfully cooked?
WILL GUIDARA: Which one have
I successfully cooked?
Out of the "Eleven Madison Park"
book, I successfully
cooked the pasta dough recipe,
so that was what I
was proud of then.
This one there's this ham and
cheese sandwich with an egg in
the top-- it's like an egg
in the hole sandwich.
And I have very nostalgic
memories of egg in holes
growing up.
So that's been the
dish that I've
accomplished at this point.
And I always tell people, hey,
if you want to second guess
whether or not this book is
accessible, I cooked out of
it, and so therefore, everyone
in this room
can cook out of it.
Dish that resonated
most with you?
DANIEL HUMM: I really
liked the--
there's a couple different
salads.
But there's a strawberry
and a cherry salad.
They're both savory, but it's
kind of using the same
philosophy.
But it's cherries, and cheese,
and there's some guanciale,
and some nuts as well.
And then with the strawberry
salad, it's kind of the same,
same principle.
It's like strawberries, red
onions, cucumbers, and as
well, like a sharp chedderesque
cheese.
And I think it's a fun way,
especially during the season,
to present a fruit
in a savory way.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DANIEL HUMM: Yup.
WILL GUIDARA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Last summer you guys had a
collaboration with Alinea, and
I was wondering what was the
experience like for you guys,
and also for your
staff as well.
WILL GUIDARA: I mean it
was unbelievable.
AUDIENCE: Trade spaces.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah.
That was a ton of work.
That was a big, big
undertaking.
But Grant and Nick are two of
our closest friends, and so in
the same way that it's fun for
us to work together, it was
kind of cool to, in a limited
engagement kind of thing, to
get to work with two other very
good friends who are also
people that we have a
ton of respect for.
And for our staffs, it was--
I mean it was the coolest thing
ever, because everyone
got to basically work in
another unbelievable
restaurant for a week.
So they got to experience a
totally different approach to
doing things without ever having
to leave their home.
It was fun.
It was inspiring.
Working with them was really,
really inspiring.
They are the kind of people who
any time they feel like
they've figured out how to do
something, they always say
again, OK, is this the
best way to do it.
And I think working with people
like that, just being
alongside people with
that, it's good.
I think the experience was
really good for both Alinea
and Eleven Madison.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DANIEL HUMM: Yes.
For us, it was one of the
highlights of my career,
really, because at first--
and Alinea was at the Eleven
Madison Park first.
And they are some of our best
friends, and we have so much
respect for.
But at the same time, we're
also competing with them.
And so the first day, we put
all of our resources fully
behind their team because
that was commitment.
But then the first day when
everyone shows up, anyone who
is important of the guests, and
our team, and me, we're
putting everything behind
another restaurant to make
them look good.
The first day that was kind of
a weird feeling, but then as
you went on, it made clear that
if you work together,
even at the restaurant we knew,
but even on a bigger
scale, if you work together
you can do just
more amazing things.
And at times, you have
to follow, and at
times you have to lead.
And even if you get
to the very top, I
think that never changes.
I think to realize that
sometimes to follow can
actually give you amazing
pleasure as well.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah.
And Monday morning is, I know
that's like the day when you
get to work and you need to jump
right into the week and
work really hard, and I thank
you all for not doing that
this morning.
[LAUGHTER]
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK:
We have one more
question before we wrap.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to say
that whatever Danny Myers did,
I'm just so impressed what you
guys have done after--
the fact that you're picking up
the mantle, passing on the
toque, whatever you
want to call it.
I remember walking into
the restaurant.
The hostess actually opened the
door for me, and that, to
me, that one gesture just blew
my mind, because it's
something that you really don't
see, because when you
walk into a restaurant,
you usually have to
open the door yourself.
So, that kind of already
set the tone for me
before I even sat down.
And again, from start to finish,
the amuse to petit
fours, the meal was one of the
best meals of my life.
Top 10 easily.
It was that kind
of experience.
I kind of just--
it's a game changer.
It makes you reevaluate what a
restaurant can do in terms of
setting up a different level
or just even setting up new
standards for every other
restaurant around York City
and across the country.
And I just want to applaud you
guys because it's really,
really outstanding.
WILL GUIDARA: Thank
you so much.
AUDIENCE: So, two-part
question.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So, what was it like
for you to understand that you
had to kind of pick up after
Kerry Heffernan?
And then also, for the front
of the house, a similar
related question.
I wanted to see what was that
kind of crazy, ah-ha moment
where you decided you wanted to
actually take over EMP from
Danny-- the Danny Meyers.
DANIEL HUMM: Well for me, I
never was concerned about
picking up from somebody.
I knew the vision we
had for the room.
I mean Eleven Madison it's one
of the most amazing dining
rooms in the world, and it was
that when I got there.
So that was my only concern.
And it took a long time.
I think what we do is
a endurance sport.
You can't just change
overnight.
So, it took a lot of work.
We're now eight years into it,
and I still feel we have a lot
of work to do.
But the one thing about Danny
Meyer is that he really was
there to support us and to
help us along the way.
We all had the same vision, and
I think we all made a lot
of sacrifice and pushed hard.
We really kept a course
altogether, and eventually,
dreams became reality.
WILL GUIDARA: I think when--
I mean I worked for Danny for a
long time, and when I would
go and do things like this, a
lot of the time people would
ask what's it like working
for Danny Meyer.
I think one of his greatest
strengths--
the importance he places on
developing culture within
restaurants I think was
revolutionary and so inspiring.
And we talk about Miles Davis
and those words and the
importance of language for
people to latch on to, such
that everyone's moving in a
consistent direction, that
undeniably came from him.
The other thing that he was
very, very good at was
empowering people and giving
people autonomy and making it
everyone who led his different
restaurants feel an amazing
sense of ownership.
We felt like and operated like
owners for years before we
actually were owners.
And it was in a lot of very
comfortable conversations with
Danny where we were trying to
figure out what we wanted out
of our lives and out of our
careers, because we do like to
think like that.
That Danny is the one that
offered us to buy the
restaurant and it just
felt natural.
And so it wasn't something that
we had to come around to.
The moment at which it was first
brought up, we already
kind of knew.
DANIEL HUMM: Also what was
interesting, like a lot of
people say, hey, how does it
feel to be an owner now?
And to be really honest, it's
not that much different.
Because, I think, because we
cared so much before, it was
our restaurant before
all along.
The first day we stepped foot
into the door, it was our
restaurant in our mind.
And I think that's why it
was never really a big
adjustment for us.
WILL GUIDARA: Yeah.
I mean and that's the culture.
And I think if you look at Kevin
Mahan or Mike Anthony at
Gramercy tavern, that's
their restaurant.
And you can kind of go through
the different restaurants in
his company, and the way he
manages to accomplish that is
pretty inspiring.
JACQUELINE WASILCZYK: Thank you
for all of your questions.
And both of you, thank you
so much for coming and
being here at Google.
WILL GUIDARA: Thank
you guys for that.
DANIEL HUMM: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]